[Music]
I study the future of crime and
terrorism and frankly I'm afraid I'm
afraid by what I see I sincerely want to
believe that technology can bring us the
techno utopia that we've been promised
but you see I've spent a career in law
enforcement and that's informed my
perspective on things I've been a street
police officer an undercover
investigator a counterterrorism
strategist and I've worked in more than
70 countries around the world I've had
to see more than my fair share of
violence and the darker underbelly of
society and that's informed my opinions
my work with criminals and terrorists
has actually been highly educational
they have taught me a lot and I'd like
to be able to share some of these
observations with you today I'm going to
show you the flip side of all those
technologies that we marvel at the ones
that we love in the hands of the Ted
community these are awesome
tools which will bring about great
change for our world but in the hands of
suicide bombers the future can look
quite different I started observing
technology and how criminals were using
it as a young patrol officer in those
days this was the height of Technology
laughs though you will all the drug
dealers and gang members with whom I
dealt had one of these long before any
police officer I knew did 20 years later
criminals are still using mobile phones
but they're also building their own
mobile phone networks like this one
which has been deployed in all 31 states
of Mexico by the narcos they have a
national encrypted radio communication
system think about that think about the
innovation that went into that think
about the infrastructure to build it
and then think about this why can't I
get a cell phone signal in San Francisco
how is this possible it makes no sense
we consistently underestimate what
criminals and terrorists can do
technology has made our world
increasingly open and for the most part
that's great
but all of this openness may have
unintended consequences consider the
2008 terrorist attack on Mumbai the men
that carried that attack out were armed
with ak-47s explosives and hand grenades
they threw these hand grenades and
innocent people as they sat eating in
cafes and waited to catch trains on
their way home from work but heavy
artillery is nothing new in terrorist
operations guns and bombs are nothing
new what was different this time is the
way that the terrorists use modern
information communications technologies
to locate additional victims and
slaughter them they were armed with
mobile phones they had BlackBerry's they
had access to satellite imagery they had
satellite phones and they even had
night-vision goggles but perhaps their
greatest innovation was this we've all
seen pictures like this on television
and in the news this is an operation
center and the terrorists built their
very own ops center across the border in
Pakistan where they monitored the BBC al
Jazeera CNN and Indian local stations
they also monitored the internet and
social media to monitor the progress of
their attacks and how many people they
had killed they did all of this in real
time the innovation of the terrorist
operation center gave terrorists
unparalleled situational awareness and
tactical advantage over the police and
over the government what did they do
with this they used it to great effect
at one point during the 60 hour siege
the terrorists were going room to room
trying to find additional victims they
came upon a suite on the top floor of
the hotel and they kicked down the door
and they found
man hiding by his bed and they said to
him who are you and what are you doing
here and the man replied I'm just an
innocent schoolteacher of course the
terrorists know that no Indian
schoolteacher stays at a suite in the
Taj they picked up his identification
and they phoned his name in to the
terrorist war room where the terrorist
war room googled him and found a picture
and called their operatives on the
ground and said your hostage is he
heavyset is he bald in front does he
wear glasses yes yes yes can the answers
the OP Center had found him and they had
a match he was not a schoolteacher he
was the second wealthiest businessman in
India and after discovering this
information the terrorist war room gave
the order to the terrorists on the
ground in Mumbai we all worry about our
privacy settings on Facebook but the
fact of the matter is our openness can
be used against us terrorists are doing
this a search engine can determine who
shall live and who shall die this is the
world that we live in
during the Mumbai siege tariffs were so
dependent on technology that several
witnesses reported that as the
terrorists were shooting hostages with
one hand they were checking their mobile
phone messages in the very other hand in
the end 300 people were gravely wounded
and over 172 men women and children lost
their lives that day think about what
happened during this 60 hour siege on
Mumbai 10 men armed not just with
weapons but with technology were able to
bring a city of 20 million people to a
standstill 10 people brought 20 million
people to a standstill and this
travelled around the world
this is what radicals can do with
openness this was done nearly four years
ago
what could terrorists do today with the
technologies available that we have what
will they do tomorrow the ability of one
to affect many is scaling exponentially
and it's scaling for good and it's
scaling for evil it's not just about
terrorism though there's also been a big
paradigm shift in crime you see you can
now commit more crime as well in the old
days it was a knife and a gun then
criminals moved to robbing trains you
could rob two hundred people on a train
a great innovation moving forward the
internet allowed things to scale even
more in fact many of you remember the
recent Sony Playstation hack in that
incidence over 100 million people were
robbed think about that when in the
history of humanity has it ever been
possible for one person to rob 100
million of course it's not just about
stealing things there are other avenues
of technology that criminals can exploit
many of you will remember this super
cute video from the last hit but not all
quadcopter swarms are so nice and cute
they'd all all have drumsticks some can
be armed with HD cameras and do counter
surveillance on protesters or as in this
little bit of movie magic quad copters
can be loaded with firearms and
automatic weapons little robots are cute
when they play music to you when they
swarm and chase you down the block to
shoot you a little bit less so of course
criminals and terrorists weren't the
first to give guns to robots we know
where that started but they're adapting
quickly recently the FBI arrested an al
Qaeda affiliate in the United States who
was planning on using these
remote-controlled drone aircraft to fly
c-4 explosives into government buildings
in the United States by the way these
travel at over 600 miles an hour
every time a new technology is being
introduced criminals are there to
exploit it we've all seen 3d printers we
know with them that you can print in
many materials ranging from plastic to
chocolate to metal and even concrete
with great precision I actually was able
to make this just the other day a very
cute little ducky but I wonder to myself
for those people that strap bombs to
their chests and blow themselves up how
might they use 3d printers perhaps like
this you see if you can print in metal
you can print one of these and in fact
you can also print one of these to the
UK I know has some very strict firearms
laws you need and bring the gun into the
UK anymore you just bring the 3d printer
and print the gun while you're here and
of course the magazines for your bullets
but as these get bigger in the future
what other items will you be able to
print the technologies are allowing
bigger printers as we move forward we'll
see new technologies also like the
Internet of Things every day we're
connecting more and more of our lives to
the Internet which means that the
Internet of Things will soon be the
internet of things to be hacked all of
the physical objects in our space are
being transformed into information
technologies and that has a radical
implication for our security because
more connections to more devices means
more vulnerabilities criminals
understand this terrorists understand
this hackers understand this if you
control the code you control the world
this is the future that awaits us
there has not yet been an operating
system or a technology that hasn't been
hacked that's troubling since the human
body itself is now becoming an
information technology as we've seen
here we're transforming ourselves into
cyborgs every year thousands of cochlear
implants diabetic pumps pacemakers and
defibrillators are being implanted in
people in the United States there are
60,000 people who have a pacemaker that
connects to the Internet the
defibrillators allow a physician at a
distance to give a shock to a heart in
case the patient needs it but if you
don't need it and somebody else gives
you the shock it's not a good thing of
course we're going to go even deeper
than the human body we're going down to
the cellular level these days up until
this point all the technologies I've
been talking about have been silicon
based ones and zeros but there's another
operating system out there the original
operating system DNA and to hackers
DNA is just an other operating system
waiting to be hacked it's a great
challenge for them there are people
already working on hacking the software
of life and while most of them are doing
this to great good and to help us all
some won't be so how will criminals
abuse this well with synthetic biology
you can do some pretty neat things for
example I predict that we will move away
from a plant-based narcotics world to a
synthetic one why do you need the plants
anymore you can just take the DNA code
from marijuana or poppies or coca leaves
and cut and paste that gene and put it
into yeast and you can take those yeast
and make them make the cocaine for you
or the marijuana or any other drug so
how we use yeast in the future is going
to be really interesting in fact we may
have some really interesting bread and
beer as we go into this next century the
cost of sequencing the human genome is
dropping precipitously it was proceeding
at Moore's law pace but then in 2008
something
the technology's got better and now DNA
sequencing is proceeding at a pace five
times that of Moore's law that has
significant implications for us it took
us 30 years to get from the introduction
of the personal computer to the level of
cybercrime we have today but looking at
how biology is proceeding so rapidly and
knowing criminals and terrorists as I do
we may get there a lot faster with bio
crime in the future it'll be easy for
anybody to go ahead and print their own
bio virus enhance versions of Ebola or
anthrax weaponized flu we recently saw a
case where some researchers made the
h5n1 avian influenza virus more potent
it already has a 70% mortality rate if
you get it but it's hard to get
engineers by moving around a small
number of genetic changes we're able to
weaponize it and make it much more easy
for human beings to catch so that not
thousands of people would die but tens
of millions you see you can go ahead and
create new pandemics and the researchers
who did this we're so proud of their
accomplishments they wanted to publish
it openly so that everybody could see
this and get access to this information
but it goes deeper than that DNA
researcher Andrew Hessel has pointed out
quite rightly that if you can use cancer
treatments modern cancer treatments to
go after one cell while leaving all the
other cells around it intact then you
can also go after any one person cell
personalized cancer treatments are the
flipside of personalized bio weapons
which means you can attack any one
individual including all the people in
this picture how will we protect them in
the future what to do what to do about
all this that's what I get asked all the
time for those of you who follow me on
Twitter I will be tweeting out the
answer later on today
actually it's a bit more complex than
that and there are no magic bullets I
don't have all the answers but I know a
few things in the wake of 9/11 the best
security Minds put together all their
innovation and this is what they created
for security if you're expecting the
people who built this to protect you
from the coming robopocalypse you may
want to have a back-up plan just saying
just think about that law enforcement is
currently a closed system its nation
based while the threat is international
policing doesn't scale globally at least
it hasn't and our current system of guns
border guards big gates and fences are
outdated in the new world into which
we're moving so how might we prepare for
some of these specific threats like
attacking a president or a prime
minister this would be the natural
government response to hide away all our
government leaders and hermetically
sealed bubbles but this is not going to
work the cost of doing a DNA sequence is
going to be trivial anybody will have it
and we will all have them in the future
so maybe there's a more radical way that
we can look at this what happens if we
were to take the president's DNA or a
king or Queens and put it out to a group
of a few hundred trusted researchers so
they could study that DNA and do
penetration testing against it as a
means of helping our leaders or what if
we sent it out to a few thousand or
controversially and not without its
risks what happens that we just gave it
to the whole public then we could all be
engaged in helping we've already seen
examples of this working well the
organized crime and corruption reporting
project is staffed by journalists and
citizens where they are crowdsourcing
what dictators and terrorists are doing
with public funds around the world and
in a more dramatic case we've seen in
Mexico a country that has been wracked
by 50,000 narcotics related murders in
the past six years
they're killing so many people they
can't even afford to bury them all in
anything but these unmarked graves like
this one outside
that Horace what can we do about this
the government has proven ineffective so
in Mexico citizens at great risk to
themselves are fighting back to build an
effective solution there crowd mapping
the activities of the drug dealers
whether or not you realize it we are at
the dawn of a technological arms race an
arms race we between people who are
using technology for good and those who
are using it for ill the threat is
serious and the time to prepare for it
is now I can assure you that the
terrorists and criminals are my personal
belief is that rather than having a
small elite force of highly trained
government agents here to protect us all
we're much better off having average and
ordinary citizens approaching this
problem as a group and seeing what we
can do if we all do our part I think
we'll be in a much better space the
tools to change the world are in
everybody's hands how we use them is not
just up to me it's up to all of us this
was a technology I would frequently
deploy as a police officer this
technology has become outdated in our
current world it doesn't scale it
doesn't work globally and it surely
doesn't work virtually we've seen
paradigm shifts in crime and terrorism
they call for a shift to a more open
forum and a more participatory form of
law enforcement so I invite you to join
me after all public safety is too
important to leave to the professionals
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]